in an exclusive interview for CBS this
morning golf icon Tiger Woods is
reflecting on his remarkable comeback
and what it means to be a dad we caught
up with him ahead of this weekend's PGA
Tour playoff event at Liberty National
Golf Club in New Jersey the 15-time
major winner has been open about his
health following a number of career
threatening injuries
but relatively private when it comes to
his family still in a rare move he
talked to us about his children and what
it meant to share this year's masters
victory with them I just wanted them to
have them to understand that what daddy
does daddy has won golf tournaments and
he's not the YouTube guy highlights of
that guy you know I'm not that guy I can
still do it and for them to see it feel
it yeah feel the electricity of the
crowd and for me to see Charlie there as
the first one it moms there and then hug
Sam I mean this is all gives me chills
just thinking about it my son plays
plays quite a bit of golf and I never
give him a lesson I unless yes yeah you
know that's you can imitate and do
whatever he wants yes whatever it does
and he'll ask you know how do you do
that and then I show them or tell I'm
alright and you help me with this but my
job is get them prepared for life not
sports not an easy job know what is the
hardest part for you in being a dad I
think the hardest thing is as any parent
you're protective you know you want the
best for me Evan will ever want to see
them hurt disappointed bummed out sad
unhappy but that's part of life too but
also it's as a paradiddle I'll finally
get stuff as we all know
my dad was a doctor yet in our family
we'd be like yeah whatever you don't
know what you're talking about are your
kids like that with you are you just dad
to them where they died am just dad
that's how they know I'm dad and you
know this whole this whole Gulf stuff is
they were both very hesitant about it
because they only remember the bad times
when I was hurt right and so they
associated Gulf with pain yeah that was
that's you know still is one of the
tougher things that they're both excited
I'm playing again but also you okay dad
you know that kind of thing because they
they remember those times when dad
couldn't get off the couch dad was
laying there and there's excited that
I'm playing and I'm happy I'm doing
something I love love to do and there
see not in me but they also stand again
they're there they're worried for for
dad
cuz they don't want their I don't want
that hurt again are you more when you
look at yourself as a parent are you
more like your mom was with you or like
your dad was with you oh definitely like
my dad definitely my my mom's tough very
very tough yeah
very vocal my dad was more cerebral and
like the plant seeds that that didn't
that wouldn't germinate for years but
there was like oh yeah that's what I'd
like to do and don't need to yell at
kids all the time I'm not like that my
mom was like that very strict more
afraid and and you know even though my
dad was a special horses I was never
really afraid of dad I talked to you
maybe probably 10 years ago maybe it was
a little bit less than that just about
your dad and what you think he would
think of who you've become as a man as a
father what do you think your dad would
think right now Pop's would be proud I
mean he says yeah you made your share
mistakes we all do and
you bounce-back learn from and you know
you always wanted me to think yeah we
all make mistakes but you know just
think about it
you know that's what I've done I've
reflected a lot I've had a lot of time
that's one on one of the hardest things
about having a backpack is that you
spend a lot of time in your head if you
can't move right and that's what I've
done a lot of meditation a lot of
thinking a lot of analyzing and here we
are come full circle I feel like I came
full circle with him too I first
interviewed him in New York City about
14 years ago had done a lot of satellite
interviews but that was the first time
in person since that first one he's
always been very generous with me about
family and sharing some of those moments
and it just puts him in I think in a
light that a lot of us don't get to see
him so human he says he looks in the
mirror sometimes he's in his 40s he sees
the 20 year old sees the 20 year old but
knows a 20 year old gets further and
further away it's so interesting to hear
him talk about his kids the way they see
the game because they see the parents
suffering that what that work they go
through - just to be able to do it you
have to think about their lives in their
lives was most of the time that he was
injured until that masters when they
hadn't seen yeah his dominance and his I
guess the joy really that came from that
weekend and it was sort of a fluke that
they were there his his kids play soccer
his daughter had lost in a golf
tournament would have been playing on
Sunday it's like hey do you want to come
to Augusta National right sure why not
and he wasn't leading at the time he was
usually the guy that was leading on
Sunday and he'd win so it was really
fate in a way maybe and that had them
there you hear so much wisdom in his
voice in terms of just his own growth as
a man and his children have a lot to do
with that yeah and his appreciation of
the game yeah because of them and also
because it was almost taken away from
him in that way and to be able to play
like that I tell you when you're when
your kids look at you and and and they
they see your pain and your struggle and
they reflect it back to you you look at
everything differently yeah they really
do there is no doubt and interview thank
you and you can watch CBS Sports
coverage of the Northern Trust the first
playoff event of this season's FedEx Cup
starting Saturday right here on CBS and
you can catch more of my conversation
with Tiger Woods on CBS this morning
Saturday
and on today's CBS this morning podcast
Woods will also share what milestone
he's hoping to achieve next year he
drops a Jack Nicklaus reference it's
great he can listen to the podcast on
your favorite platform